[Müzik]
Evet abs'nin gülü Hadi
Bismillahirrahmanirrahim şimdi geldim
neye tarihin metoduna değil mi Bak şimdi
Daha başlamadan tarih bir bilimdir Tamam
bilgi değildir tarih bir bilimdir Niye
Çünkü bizim de yöntemimiz var taramam
tasnif tahlil Tenkit terkip ne ararsan
hepsi bizde de mevcut Tamam bir Ar
tartışılıyordu bilim midir bilgi midir
falan diye tarih bir bilimdir Hatta
bilimlerin hasıdır anasıdır babasıdır
tarihsiz asla ve kata olmaz tamam şimdi
Ark Aslan dinle beni geldim bu Karadayım
tarihin metodu değil mi şimdi bak şimdi
ben sana bir ödev verdim okuldayız değil
mi ya işte şeyde ben sana bir ödev
verdim dedim ki git dedim 16 yüzyıl
Osmanlı işte yükselme dönemindeki
sadrazamları araştır dedim ne alt
edeceksin Ne yapacaksın hemen Tabii sen
şu an şanslısın Niye sen teknoloji
çocuğusun E biz Neydik b kütüphane
çocuğuyduk değil mi Bak bunun altına
öyle yorumlar yapmam ümüz sıkarım
Vallaha bak ha tamam E biz ne yapıyorduk
kütüphanede gidip katalog tanıyorduk
bilmem ne yapıyorduk kitap arıyorduk Onu
buu yapıyorduk Sen şanslısın Niye Çünkü
sende Google var Hemen Google'a şak diye
yazarsın ya Benim oğlan İlteriş bile ad
İlkokulu 1E başladı okuma yazmayı
öğrendi tamam Daha yeni öğrendi daha
öncesinden YouTube'dan video açacak
mikrofona basıyordu Pepe diyordu O şak
diye açılıyordu E sen de aynı Hemen
Google'a yazarsın değil mi İşte dersin
ki 15 yüzyıl Osmanlı Adır azamlı diyee
şak diye s oradan ben çıkarır listeler
bilmem neler gelir değil mi İşte o
yaptığın işlemin adı kaynak taraması dır
gid Anladın mı kaynak taraması dır Sen
şanslısın Biz Vallahi uğraşıyoruz Peki
tarihin kaynakları nelermiş bir onlara
bakalım tarihin kaynakları hop hemen
ışınlandı bu yanınına neymiş tarihin
kaynaklarını mebin kitabı mebin bu
seneki kitabı Tamam yeni güncellenen
kitabı tarihin kaynaklarını dört
başlıkta incelemiş tarih yazılı
kaynakları yazısız kaynakları sesli
görüntülü ve eşy neser olmak üzere Biz
önceden bunu derdik ki yazılı yazısız
yazılı işte üzerinde yazılı Çizi olanlar
yazısız üzerinde yazı Çizi olmayanlar
sesli görüntülü Der geçerdik şimdi MEB
kitabında böyle resim şekil şembelek
falan bir sürü bir şeyler koy vermişler
şimdi bakalım tarihin yazılı kaynakları
Hah bunlar bize güvenirlik için daha
sağlamdır daha iyidir değil mi Aha
Yazılı kaynaklar ne onlar abem yazı
çıktığında A4 mü vardı adam nereye
yazıyor nereye yazıyordu kil Tabletlere
yazıyordu bak Kil tablet varsa yazı
vardır tamam Daha sonrasında ne çıktı
parşömenler papirüsler Çıktı bunları
Mutlak surette şıkların içine atarlar
Tamam beraberinde kitabeler arşiv
belgeleri değil mi mektuplar gazeteler
kronikler o takvim gibi böyle
sıralamalar yok mu 1 Ocak 1920'de şu
oldu 2 Ocak 1920'de şu oldu 3 Ocak
1920'de şu oldu diy gün gün getirdiler
kırık deniyor onlara Berat Berat ne
Berat Osmanlı'daki atama tayin
yazılarıdır tamam mı Ah sen şimdi E
üniversiteyi kazanacaksın okuyacaksın ya
Ondan sonrasında ne olacak KPSS sınavına
diye işte devet memurlu sınavı diye
artık AGS Onun adı da değişiyor O sınava
girdiğinde tamam mı İşte şu falanca
kuruma filanca yere Ataman yapıldı diye
mesaj gelecek ya sana işte onun adı
neymiş Berat mış atama tayin terfi
yazısıyım bilin anlaşmalar bak yazılıdır
değil mi Ama burada bir şey var Ne var
para var para para bak paralar da
yazılıdır nasıl abim Şu an cebinden
çıkar bir 1 lirayı bir bak üstüne neler
var Bak bir paradan kaç tane yorum
çıkıyor işte seret sen şimdi dinle Bak
mesela çıkardın değil mi cebinden bil
lirayi bak he Yukarıda bir tane TC var
mı al devletin adı çıktı TC kısaltması
çıktı yanında bitki motifleri var mı var
bak ikinci bilgimiz değil mi Mustafa
Kemal'in silüeti var mı var E çevirdin
öbür tarafı Türkiye Cumhuriyeti yazıyor
devletin adı ve rejimi var mı bak 5
bilgiye geldik Şu an arkasından 1 Türk
lirası diyor bak işte Latin harfleri
değil mi Türk şey çıktı lira para birimi
çıktı E tarih var orada bak 10 tane
bilgi yaşıyorsun ve bir de o paralar
yazılı Bak bil ve bir de o bastırılan
paranın madeni Tamam o ülkenin Ekonomik
düzeyi hakkında bilgi verir mesela para
bakırdan yorumla Fakır fakir diyeceksin
fakirler işte bakır Fakır fakir öyle
diyeceksin peki para gümüşten Oo
birazcık bitik kanlanmış iyi diyeceksin
peki para altınd dansa süper zengin
diyeceksin Peki Bitcoin ise o zaman
uçmuş gitmiş diyeceksin anlaştık abim al
o bastırılan paranın madeni bile o
ülkenin Ekonomik düzeyi hakkında Sana
bilgi veri Düşünsene cebindeki paraların
altın olduğunu Çil Çil altın
çıkarıyorsun böyle Osmanlı gibi böyle
işte şeyle ödüyorsun değil mi İşte para
der değil mi Mesela sikke gi
kullanabilir Ne bileyim işte Mangır
diyebilir değil mi Akça kuruş bir sürü
ne var para birimi var Bunları
kullanabilir ışıkların içine atarlar
düşme para yazılıymış bileceksin
öğretmenim Osmanlı paraları yazılı mıydı
Evet onlarda da yazı var tarih var bir
şeyler var dersti Konstantin yenebilen
bir şeyler yazıyor üstünde tamam mı ha
sakın da o paraya bakıp da tamam mı bana
şöyle çok adamlar çıktı geldi bana dedi
ki ya hocam dedi benim elimde dedi bir
para var dedi ee Hocam dedi Üzerinde
dedi 1315 yazıyor dedi Ee dedi 800 sene
öncesinin parası dedi Nasıl okuturuz onu
dedi Dedim ki Ulan dedim saf o dedim o
dedim şey hicri takvime göre onun üstüne
dedim 585 koy tamam mı O para dedim
1900'lerin başındaki para 1890
1900'lerin başındaki para O para dedim
senin düşündüğün gibi 800 yıllık para
değil dedim o paradan Etrafta çok fazla
var Sen de biliyorum çünkü bana çok
geldi öyle Hocam bu paranın üstünde ne
yazıyor diye bak Durdur altap yap
Osmanlı paraları üstünde ne yazıyor de
kalıp abem kalıp kalıp aynı günümüzdeki
paralarda da aynısı var bil paralar
neymiş tarihin yazılı
kaynaklarıyla yazı Çizi varsa yazılı
kaynak Tamam peki Peki yazsız kaynaklar
Aha onlara neler destanlar Efsaneler
mitler menkibeler değil mi Aha şimdi
buradan şuna geri geleceğim Şurayı
tamamlayayım destanlara geleceğim
özellikle soracak sen de inşallah
düşmezsin değil mi peki beraberinde
artık güncele baktığınız zaman sesli
görüntü kaynaklar E artık belgeseller
videolar değil mi ses kayıtları haritası
fotoğrafı her şeyi var mı e var I Dünya
Savaşı ile alakalı adamlar saldırırken
video çekmişler kurban oldum E şimdi
bile günümüzde bile mesela Telegram
kanallarında görmüyor musunuz mu canlı
canlı haber kavga vuruş kuruş o oraya
füze atıyor o buna bilmem ne atıyor e o
onu havaya uçuruyor hepsinin görüntüsü
kaydı var Fotoğraflarda mesela
enlerinden birisi Hitler tarihin ilk
sisini yapmış
nerede Paris'i işte Fransa'yı işgal
ediyor Paris'te Eyfel kulesinin önünde
böyle anladın Aha ya Bak bunlar işte
şeyler sesli görüntülü kaynaklar
beraberinde eşya nesneler ne onlar
arkeolojik kalıntılar adam kazıyor
kazıyor kazıyor kazıyor bir tane çanak
buluyor çömlek buluyor bir şey buluyor
silah buluyor Kalkan buluyor mier
buluyor Al bak bunlar neser işte süs
eşyası çakı Çakmak Ayna tarak incik
boncuk çek asıl kopar sündür milyona ne
alırsan buradan al ne alırsan milyona al
Emel Sayın da buradan aldı 5 milyon
borcu kaldı eşya nesneler bunl da bak
bak mesela fibula fibula ne fibula A bu
frit derin şeylerin kullandığı Çengelli
ne la zamanında bunu altın sınıflara o
zaman OKS miydi SBS miydi adı 2007'de mi
8de mi 9'da mı ne öyle bir tarihte
soruydu Genel kültür olsun O ne ya deyip
kalma anlaştık ve Mesela sana bir de
ayrıca bir yorum süs
eşyası özel mülkiyeti gösterir
mi özel
mülkiyeti gösterir niye yüzük benim
yüzüğüm Allah bizi bu ay yıldızlı yüzün
bu ay yıldızın Aha öbür tarafta da var
bir tane tamam Allah beni bu albayrağın
gölgesi inden ayırmasın Ben Gitsem de bu
yüzük Barna da kalır allah'ınız dilen al
süs eşyası Aha Ankara valiliğinden
hediye gelen mavi Turkuaz taşlı incikli
boncuklu bir şey bileklik değil mi A bak
bunlar ne bunlar hep nedir süs eşyası
değil mi Aha Senin kullandığın şeyler
küpeler işte kolyeler broşlar Bunlar
özel mülkiyeti gösterir Tamam klasik
yorumlardır Bunlar bileceksin bir tamam
fibulanın çengelliiğne
fibula işte bir fibula versene de he
dediğinde Aman Allah'ım ne kadar
cahilsin ya bir biraz kitap oku bir
kendin geliştir bir kültür bir
Instagram'dan çık artık de ona tamam
fibula Çengel liği neymiş Bak Genel
kültür olsun ha Bunlar tarihin
kaynakları ama ama şu destanlar
Efsaneler mitler menkıbeler tamam mı Bak
destan efsane Bunlar tarihin yazısız
kaynağıdır yazısız Bunlar neler Bunlar
tarihin sözlü kaynaklarıdır anlaştık
mesela ve bunlar tarihte Tamam çok da
itibar görmez Niye Çünkü destanlar
atmasyon dur Anladın mı Mesela bir Oğuz
Kağan Destanı var bizde Abo Oğuz Kağan
doğmamış ağaca yıldırım düşüyor içinden
Oğuz Kağan çıkıyor Ben geldim diyor
Tamam başınıza ben geçeceğim diyor ondan
sonras Hey kadın beni emzir diyor Tamam
ondan sonra bu ne ya diyor Kımız verin
diyor bir günlük bebek ikinci gün Karnım
acıktı deyip geyik avıa gidiyor 3üncü
gün uğraş lazım Türkiye deyip şeye
gidiyor çin'le savaşmaya gidiyor Anladın
mı yani destanlar biraz o mitler
Efsaneler Hele ki mesela o mitler lan
MİT deyince bizim istihbarat değil Ha
tamam mı Mit myth diye geliyor ya mitler
Efsaneler Yunan efsaneleri Mesela işte
Tanrı zeusla bilmem kim Apollo işte
falan falana giderken 5 kilo osmancık
pirinç a işte bilen anlayana işte Ne
neyse Ama bunlar tarihe kaynak değildir
Bak üstüne basarak söylüyorum soru
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi tarihin yazılı
kaynaklarından değildir diye sorar sazan
gibi düşersin hangisi tarihin yazılı
kaynağı değildir Kil tablet Papirüs
parşomen Berat destan der Celal Hoca
öğrenci
mod Kil tablet bilemedim hiç duymadım
pap parşomen ne lan bunlar ne ki acaba
parşomen parşomen Papirüs bilemedim aah
Berat destan destan kesin yazılı diyor
öğrenci kardeş destanlar tarihin sözlü
kaynaklarıdır hangisi yazılı kaynak
değildir sorusunun cevabı destandır ve
bizler destanları çok kaile almayız niye
E atmasyon çünkü Tamam yani içinde
kulaktan kulağa kulaktan kulağa gele
gele gele gele gele gele g gele Herkes
kendinden bir şeyleri eklemiş mesela En
Sevdiğim destanlardan birini anlatı
vereceğim sana tamam
mı Nereye yazayım şuraya yazayım
Vazgeçtim şuraya yazacağım
tispe
prometus
al Latince bilir misiniz Onu da
öğreteceğim ben size tispe prometus
arkana yaslan Listen to çok veri
tamam mı retro Yayıncılık ışıkları
karart Işık ambiyans ver bana tamam mı
Story Time Arkan ayaslan dinle bundan
7512 yıl önce Tamam Antik Yunan'da bir
cuma mübarek günü sabah ezanından sonra
iki tane komşu evde iki tane çocuk doğdu
bir kız çocuğu bir de oğlan çocuğu doğdu
kız çocuğuna tispe dediler oğlan
çocuğuna prometus dedi dediler Tamam ve
aynı gün aynı saatte doğdular Bundan tam
7512 yıl önce ben de oradaydım Tamam ve
bu çocuklar beraber oynamaya başladılar
beraber güldüler koştular atladılar
falan falan derken büyümeye başladıkça
aralarındaki arkadaşlık
ilişkisi şiddetli fırtınalı bir aşka
dönüştü ya ha öyle bacım bacım yok yani
hani tamam mı Al müthiş bir aşka dönüştü
gençler Birbirlerini çok sevdiler tamam
Yunanistan Büyükşehir Belediyesi'nin ne
kadar Parkı bahçesi ağacı varsa her yere
Bunlar TP TP TP TP böyle döşeli her yere
kalpler Bilmem öpücükler her şeyleri
koymuşlar birbirlerine döme bile
yapmışlar TP TP falan diye tamam Şu
bileğe yazı yazıyorlar ya A o dönem
başlamış Tamam ve aradan yıllar geçtikçe
yıllar kızımız tispe yaramış tispe 90 60
görenlerin
good dediği fıstık gibi güzel sarışın
beyaz tenli mavi gözlü afeti Devran bir
hatuna dönüşmüş yıllar aynı şekilde
oğlumuz işte prusa da yaramış yakışıklı
Kaslı iri karizma Aynı ben gibi böyle
böyle şey bir sağlam bir delikanlı olmuş
Tamam ama birbirlerini çok seviyorlar
Lakin bu aşka ne kızın anası ne oğlanın
babası müsaade etmiyor niye Düşünsene
kızın anası olduğunu dünyalar güzeli
kızın bu sümüklü promüsli mi beraber
olacak e Düşünsene oğlanın babası
olduğunu değil mi ya senin yakışıklı
karizma seksi oğlun y işte kraliçeler ne
bileyim Sultanlar prensesler dururken
değil mi buik şeyle mi tiple mi beraber
olacak değil mi Anası ve oğlanın babası
kızın anasıyla oğlanın babası bunların
görüşmelerini yasaklamış Tamam ve ama
işte azimle Bunlar duvarı delmiş bir gün
piremus duvarı böyle yani komşu evler ya
böyle piremus uğraşa uğraşa ede Kıla
Kıla Kıla Kıla oraya öyle priz gibi
delmiş al tarihin ilk priz deliğini de
kim açtı premius Açtı o küçücük delikten
Bunlar sevgiler birbirlerine bakarlar
Konuşurlar saçını koklar öpücük atar
bilmem ne yapar böyle böyle falan falan
derken kızın zalım AB beyi Marcus aelius
Antonius Maximus Tamam bir bakıyor
delikten lan öbür taraftan Anam resim
resim lan yarım kilo alçıyı aldığıyla
şak diye duvarı kapatıyor Tamam gençler
birbirini göremiyor bizim prometus böyle
Yunanistan Büyükşehir Belediyesinin
kabesinde Çınaraltı kabesinde Ah ah
sevdiğim neredesin falan böyle pozlar
falan bilmem neler verirken B zaman
geçtikten sonra Kızın annesi Şunu fark
ediyor Ulan kızı diyor eve kapattık
bunları görüştürmüyor Ama artık eve kız
istemeye Kimse gelmiyor diyor o kızı ne
yapmak lazım göstermek lazım ki millet
gelsin sen o arada da ayın sonunda köyün
muhtarının oğlunun sünnet düğünü var mı
var değil mi Hemen haber gidiyor biz de
düğüne geleceğiz Kızımız da gelecek
Orada diyor tamam mı orada O da diyor
Kaydır kubak Cemile'yi Oynayı verecek
diyor Tamam haberi alan prometus hemen
gidiyor saç sakal tıraşını olduktan
sonra briyantin de vurduktan sonra
Parfümü de sıktıktan Sonra erkenden
düğün yerine gidiyor hemen orada ork
çalan arkadaş bunun ehbab iym Tamam öyle
dinliyor beni kurban oldum mu ya ben
Anladın abem sen dinle tamam öyle diyor
ki bak lan diyor oğlum diyor yengen
gelecek diyor manita gelecek diyor tamam
mı Ee bak diyor yengen geldiği anda
diyor benim türküyü vur diyor tamam mı
Ne istiyorsun sen oğlum sen benim
türküyü bilmiyor musun diyor benim
türküyü Vur işte diyor Tamam sonra
Bizimki takım elbisesini giymiş Tamam
aslan gibi bir bakıyor ki sevdiği tispe
annesiyle beraber Salına Salına geliyor
değil mi Hemen diyor ki Hey Yiğitler
Yiğidi Efeler Efesi Vur benim türküyü
dediğinde arkadan Hemen giriyor Deniz
Üstü
Köpürür
Hey canım rinn nay Rinna rinn Nay bizim
premius Efe böyle Deniz Üstü Köpürür
Oynayı vermiş sevdiğine karşı hemen
tispe geldiğinde gidiyor Orçun'un yanına
hemen diyor sen di şu şarkıyı çalar
mısın diyor peçeteyi yazmış Vermiş şarkı
ne oy Far fara Far fara böyle
oynarlarken bizimki böyle oynarken
arkasında tispe oynarken diyor ki kız
bana kaçar mısın diyor O da diyor ki
Kaçmaz mıyım lan geri zekalı diyor tamam
mı O zaman diyor yarın öğle namazından
sonra köyün çıkışındaki çeşmede beni
bekle kaçalım bu diyardan Ya benimsin ya
kara toprağın diyor tamam mı oynayarak
ayrılıyor
ertesi gün sabah erkenden kalkıyor
prometus Tamam hemen giyiniyor Kuşan
camiye koşturuyor Tamam hemen arkasından
beraberinde kız da hazırlanıyor
babasıyla abisi gittikten sonra o da
tüye cim diyor Tamam ve kız abileri
babası evden çıktığı anda 12 tane Çekçek
valizi çeyizi Karaca'dan 12 kişilik
yemek takımını Ne bilem Neyi tamam mı
ayır fayını arkasından o dınını bunların
hepsini koydu yla çantaya pır evden
kaçıyor köyün çıkışındaki Çeşmeye doğru
gidi diyor gittiğinde Bir de ne görsün
yerde bir aslan yatmış ağzı yüzü Kan
revan içinde sanırsın ki belediyenin
t500 otobüsü çarpmış metrobüs çarpmış
tamam böyle beyninden vurulmuşa dönüyor
onun aklına da sizin aklınıza gelen
geliyor çok sevdiği promete usunu Aslan
mı yedi diyor Aman Allah'ım ben onu çok
seviyordum neden böyle oldu Hayır
inanamıyorum ben onsuz yaşayamam ölürüm
deyip hüngür hüngür ağlamaya başlıyor O
arada boynundaki FL ı yere düşürüyor
Çekçek valizlerini bırakıyor Tamam
koşarak oradan ağlayarak uzaklaşıyor
gidiyor koşuyor koşuyor ağlıyor koşuyor
ağlıyor koşuyor en son bir mağaraya
geliyor orada kapaklanır hüngür hüngür
hüngür ağlıyor kızımız ağlaya Dursun
hiçbir şeyden habersiz prometus hemen
çıktığı yyla koştur koştur köyün
çıkışındaki Çeşmeye geldiğinde bir de ne
görsün yerde bir aslan ağzı yüzü Kan
revan içinde Tamam ve sevdiğinin
valiziyle de fuları orada beyninden
vurulmuşa dönüyor onun aklına da senin
aklına gelen geliyor çok sevdiği tisp
esini Aslan mı yedi Bizimki Ağlama falan
hiçbir şey yok prometus adamdı Tamam
çekiyor
hançerini ya rabbel alemin diyor bu can
onsuz yaşar mı sandın birini birini
aldın beni ne bıraktın ben onsuz yaşar
mıyım diye çektiği ile hançerini tisp
sevgisiyle dolu kalbine Hançeri saplıyor
ve oracıkta diz çöküp kan gölüne dönen
Deryada orada ruhunu teslim ediyor Oğlan
kendini öldürmüş bak erkekler
adamdır kız uzaklarda ağla ağla ağla
gözyaşları kurumuş Tamam diyor acaba
içine bir ukte içine bir ateş düşüyor
Acaba ben sevdiğimi göremedim aslan yedi
zannettim kaçtım Aslında o aslanın
yediği başka bir avdı da ya sevdiğim
geldi de beni göremedi O ne yaptı ki
içinde bir umut Oysa Bir Umuttu diye
koştur koştur geldiğinde birden ne
görsün çok sevdiği promosu onu bırakıp
kaçmamış Onun yaptığını yapmamış Sen
beni benim sevdiğimden daha çok
seviyormuşsun senin aşkın benimkinden
daha büyükmüş Allah'ım birini aldın beni
ne bıraktın deyip sevdiğinin boynuna
sarılıp göğsündeki Hançeri çıkarıp kendi
göğsüne saplamış ve iki sevgili orada
birbirlerine sarılıp ruhlarını teslim
teslim
etmişler Ağa be Tam burada vallahi var
ya bir çay içidir değil mi he ve bu
durumu izleyen Yunan zibidi tanrıları
Zeus Apollo Artemis işte ne Ne bilem
nesi tamam mı bunlar atenas bilmem nesi
Bunlar Sen yaprak dökümünün finalini
İzler gibi Bihter Behlül'ün finalini
İzler gibi Allah'ım ağla ağla ağla salya
sümük aşağıya inmişler iki sevgilinin
birbirlerine kapaklanmak
ağacın meyvesine oğlanın
akmaktan Göle dönen kanını ağacın
meyvesine vermişler kızın akmaktan
kuruyan gözyaşlarını ağacın ağacın
yapraklarına vermişler O ağacın
meyvesini yediğinizde elinize prometus
kanı bulaşır o kanı Dünya üzerinde
çıkaracak Tek şey ise sevdiğinin
gözyaşları yani ağacın yaprak O ağacın
latince ismi tispe promete usur Türkçe
karşılığı ise kar
duttur Hakikaten de karadutu yediğinde
eline bulaşır onu çıkaracak tek şey
sevgilisinin gözyaşları ağacın
yapraklarıdır
nasıl destan Ulan ne sevgiler varmış be
bizim manita bizi aramaz diyorsun değil
mi sınav zamanı manita mita yok sen hele
iyi bir üniversiteyi kazan prometus da
tispe de seni bulur bak anlattığım
destan nasıl Harika değil mi ama tamamen
atmasyon hikayenin Saade şimdi şu
Destana bakacak olursan Ulan 7512 yıl
önce sabah namazı kılınıyordu Oy farfara
vardı Deniz Üstü Köpürür vardı değil mi
E Dyson Air fryer vardı Anladın mı
abiciğim olayı neye göre bak günümüze
göre işte destanlar atmasyon O yüzden
destanlar tarihte bizde kaynak olarak
tercih edilmez kullanılmaz Tamam ve Ey
videoyu izleyen kız kardeşim Ey bro
Tamam Allah size tipinizi promu nasip
etsin ama sınavdan sonra önce ders
Birinizin yanında Vallaha görürsen bak
vallaha bak ben Düşünsene benim senin
abin
olduğumu fena başa bela önce ders Tamam
al destan mes lan Nereden nereye geldik
biz kurban oldum mu ya vallahi billahi
al Aha şimdi bir sürü tarih metoduna
geri döndüm Bir sürü kaynaklar araması
yaptık mı yaptık değil mi Al bir sürü
yazılı çizili sözlü belgesel eşya meşya
Bilmem çanak çömlek bir sürü bir şeyimiz
var değil mi Ne yapacağım ben bunları
Hemen bunları bir tasnif edeceğim yani
ayıracaksın sonra tahlil aşaması
başlayacak yani
inceleme oturacaksın inceleyecek
okuyacaksın tek tek bakacaksın ne
anlatıyor lan bu diyeceksin değil mi
Sonra kafanda bir şeyler oluşur mu değil
mi sonra diğer aşama Ne o tenkit sordu
bunu ÖSYM bak haberiniz olsun ha
eleştiri aşaması şimdi buldum tamam mı
araştırıyordu ulan bir adam
araştırıyordum o adam hakkında 99 tane
kitap yerin dibine sokmuş tamam mı
eleştirmiş de sövmüş hatta adamı tamam
ama bir tane kitap var ki o adamı Yere
göğe sığdıramıyor Allah'ım adamı böyle
yukarılara çıkaracağım diye öve öve
anlatmış Bir araştırdın baktın ki o
kitabı o adamın kayın biraderi yazmış
bak eleştirirsen dersin ki bu adam bunun
akrabası olduğu için objektif
davranmamış 99 tanesi işte yerin dibine
sokmuş bu objektif değildir Bu
taraflıdır dersin eleştirirsen değil mi
şimdi ilk aşamam neydi metotta bir önce
bir kaynakları taradım 2 tasnif ettim
sınıflandırdı yazılı görsel çizili
belgesel Neyse ayırdım 3 numara oturdum
tahlile incelemeye başladım 4 numara
yalan yanlış olanını eleştirdim değil mi
5 numara son terkip yani sentez aşaması
artık kafanda onunla alakalı bir şeyler
ortaya çıktı mı Evet çıktı bunun
sonucunda da ne ortaya çıkar bunun
sonucunda da artık ürünün eserin kitabın
makaleniz o ortaya çıkar tarihin bak
böyle bir neyi var özelliği var anlaştık
yattı mı aklına ezberleme Neyi anla
mantığı anla ve şu kaynaklarda da şu
mantık da var Onu da şuraya yazı vereyim
birinci elden kaynak ikinci elden kaynak
Ondan sonra bitirelim bakalım Ne o
birinci elden kaynak bunu da sordu Çünkü
ÖSYM tamam bir de ne var ikin
elden kaynaklarımız var değil mi Bak
bulabildiğiniz mesela değil mi Fatih
devrinden mesela Berat Fatih'in yazdığı
mektup Fatih'in bastırdığı para Bak
bunlar birinci elden kaynaktır anlaştık
ha ik elden kaynak ne işte birinci elden
kaynaktan faydalanarak yazılanlar ikinci
elden kaynaktır mesela Osmanlı'da kardeş
katline çalışıyorum tamam mı hemen
gittim Başbakanlık Osmanlı arşivine
Hemen oradan Fatih'in kardeş katli
fermanını buldum çıkardım Tamam Ferman
da aynen şöyle yazıyor ve her kimesneye
evladından Saltanat Müyesser ola nizamı
alem için karındaşın katli caiz ola
nizamı alem için karın taşının katli
caiz ola eksar ulema dahi bu şekilde
tecviz evliye anı namil olalar Sultan
ikici Mehmet Han El Muzaffer daima Hah
bu ne Ne dedim ben be dedim ki
çocuklarından kime Saltanat geçerse
kardeşinin katli nizam-ı alem için
caizdir ulemanın çoğunluğu da buna fetva
vermiştir bununla başarılı olsunlar
dedii Sultan katan Ben şimdi buna
bakarak bu orijinal birinci elden
kaynağa bakarak Ben de bir ne yazdım ben
de bir makale yazdım e Benimki Ne oldu
benimki ikinci elden kaynak oldu doğru
mu peki senin de performans ödevin
bilmem ne ödevin Osmanlı'da Fatih Mehmet
Devri idi değil mi E sen Başbakanlık
Osmanlı arşivine gidip Osmanlıca kaynak
çalışabilir mi Naim Davut çalışamazsın E
sen ne yapacaksın ya sen de benden
bakarak yazdın Peki Seninki kaçıncı el
oldu o 3 diyen ağzın üstü ş bir tane
vurdun mu Seninki de ikinci el oldu aynı
ne gibi cep telefonu gibi araba gibi
gittin kutusuyla aldın birinci elden
sattığın anda ikinci elden o ona
sattığında ikinci el O ana ikinci el o
ona ikinci el anladın birinci elden
ikinci elden kaynak meselesi de budur en
eski kaynaklardır Tamam bitti şimdi
metodu Hallettik tekrarlıyorum Bak ben
olsam yazılıda falan sorarım yani hani
tamam A Kutan mışta 9 sınıf yazılısında
hocası sordu tanımı sordu tanım durumu
sordu özellikleri sordu deney gözlem yok
sordu bunu sordu gelir bunlar yazılıda
karşınıza Tamam bilin Tamam ve tarih
öğretmenleri kıymetli meslektaşlarım
tarih tarihte de işte alan sınavında da
mesela buradan gelir hangisi işte
anlatır bu aşama hangi aşamadır der
Tamam sordu bunu yani Hani bu işte
kaynak taraması Tamam tasnif tahlil
tenkit terkip 5 aşama tam 5 tane
değiştir birini sor gelsin ÖSYM'nin
teknik Peki şimdi geldim neye gel bu
kameradayken
ilmes öğretilmesini uzmanlaşması
kolaylaştırmak amacıyla ne yapacağım
bunu bak Amaç ne amaç kolaylaştırmak
dayı ya kolaylaştırmak zorlaştırma
kolaylaştır bizim düsturumuz bu şimdi
kurban oldum tarih insanla başlar dedik
Hazreti Adem'den beri var tarih insan
insan faaliyetleri diyoruz ya E şimdi
koca bilmem kaç milyar yıllık her şeyi
benim akımda tutmam mümkün mü Değil
Değil mi Biz de o yüzden
bölmüşüm şü neler işte işte k
Çağ mesela Yontma Taş değil mi
beraberinde işte cidal taş bilmem ne
sonra ne başlıyor ilk çağ Başlıyor sonra
ne başlıyor Orta Çağ sonra ne var Yeni
Çağ günümüzde de ne var mesela Yakın Çağ
var değil mi E bak bunlara göre bölünmüş
mesela Yeni Çağ diye al hepsinin belli
zaman aralıkları var mı var ya da buraya
yazabilirsiniz tamam mı atıyorum 15
yüzyıl gördün mü
Yüzyıl Bak bu neye göredir zamana
göredir ve Bir de neye göre bölmüş e
dünyada kardeş yde insan yaşıyor bir
antarktik hariç penger var orada kurban
olduğum e mekana göre bölmüş ne diye
mesela tamam mı
Asya
Avrupa değil mi
Anadolu mesela yere göre bölmüş
amerika'sı bilmem nesi işte Güney
amerika'sı Latin amerika'sı Avustralya
diye bölmüş ve bir de konuya göre bölmüş
nasıl Siyasi Tarih savaşlar barışlar
bilm Er mesela giriyor değil mi
beraberinde on 295 294 bir şey sayıyordu
tamam Siyasi Tarih beraberinde işte eee
kültürel tarih değil mi Mesela sanat
tarihi Bilim Tarihi gibi gibi gibi gibi
gibi gibi bir sürü çıkar değil mi şimdi
ben size ne olduğumu söyleyeyim Tamam
ben de akademik tarihçi olaraktan ben
yeni çağda yeni
çağda Avrupa Anadolu'da siyasi
kültür uzmanıyım Ben de anladın bak
nokta atışı Hani nasıl doktor var göz
doktoru değil mi Ha genel her şeyi
biliyor ama Gözde uzman Bizim de
uzmanlığımız burasıdır niye böyle bir
şey yapıyormuşuz tarihi araştırmasını
öğrenmesini öğretmesini uzmanlaşması
kolaylaştırmak için yapıyormuşuz dedim
ve orta kamera sana dedim ki derslerini
Yarım saatte bitireceğim dedim bitti
gitti Tam 30 dakika
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere haydi
bakalım Allah'a emanet
[Müzik]